[Music]
[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm cabby HD here
and I just want to give a shout out to
my former self so I was at that Apple
event a bunch of months ago when they
were announcing the new iPhone and all
that stuff and they also dropped air
pods that they would be making these
wireless earbuds for iPhones and then
they announced the price and I tweeted
this clearly I was not a believer but
today in January 2017 air pods may be
the most popular wireless headphones on
planet Earth and if they're not yet
they're certainly well on their way to
being those I see these everywhere I see
these out in New York City I see them at
airports I see them at CES I'm just so
used to seeing these in people's ears
there's thousands of reviews and they're
great reviews people are going out and
getting these on purpose as gifts for
themselves
they're out of stock for the holidays
they're definitely doing really well so
in a way this falls right in line with
the whole getting rid of the headphone
jack thing as much as it sucks at first
you have to do it eventually if you want
to get wireless technology to improve
really quickly so right around the time
that Apple's getting rid of the
headphone jack
they also come out with what they feel
is the best possible wireless headphones
and that puts pressure on everyone else
who wants to be competitive
now marques wait are you are you
changing your tone on this like you were
hating on these but now suddenly these
are the best possible wireless
headphones yes I reviewed them I used
them you can watch that video these are
the best possible wireless earbuds
obviously if you like over ear
headphones those are a different
category but nothing comes close to
airpot as a recap here's what makes them
so good three things number one the case
it's super simple you just open it take
the headphones out put them back in it
charges them while they're in here and
you can charge the case it's small it's
really good number two the W one chip
inside pairing this with an iPhone takes
literally two seconds thanks to that
chip as soon as you open the case it's
working and as soon as you pair it you
can start listening but not only that
once
you pair it to your iPhone for example
it automatically is available to pair
with any other Apple device you have
signed in thanks to iCloud and that ship
so that is legit and three is just use
of use the whole experience you want to
listen to music you open the case
put the air pods in and you're listening
to music it's already started playing if
you're done you take them out of your
ears it stopped playing you put them
back in the case you close it it's
disconnected it's off it's charging
again it's ready to go the next time you
need it simple the battery life is solid
the sound is good enough for most people
I mean if you're doing phone calls and
just casually listening to music that's
all people really want and for most
people they stay in your ears pretty
well when walking around or during a
commute or normal activity I know some
people that even work out in these it's
definitely not for everyone but it's
still true for most so the question is
what if you're on Android like what's
the best wireless earbuds for Android
what's the what's gonna match the entire
air pods for iPhone experience if you
use an Android phone
well after testing a bunch as you saw in
the intro and I got to be honest my
findings were not predictable or easy
but I came to the conclusion that none
of them do everything as well as air
pods they all do different things better
than others but it's sort of a mixed bag
here is what you would think most likely
would be that equivalent pixel buds made
by Google for Android so those same
prices air pods and their Bluetooth and
they have instant pairing if you have a
pixel but otherwise it's normal
bluetooth pairing with any Android phone
as soon as you take it out the case the
sound is pretty good as far as audio
quality nothing exactly mind-blowing
here for the price the battery life is
about the same and you can see they're
not truly wireless earbuds so they do
have this wire between them and they
actually stay in your ears through that
pretty clever wire method I know there
aren't technically wireless headphones
because of that but you can push the
wire right up through the earbud to
create this little modular custom sized
wingtip to fit your ear and it works
pretty well also the wire carries power
between the earbuds so like don't ever
cut this wire I think your ability to
control everything is right around on
par with air pods so you can move
forward or backwards between songs but
if you want to change the volume you
have to ask Google assistant which you
do by holding down on the side of your
but on the right it responds to you
pretty quickly and it's
natural enough that I don't find it that
weird it also reads your notifications
as they come in so like a calendar event
as it happens it'll just read it to you
or a text message and a DoubleTap on the
touchpad will just read off everything
you have waiting for you there's also
the live translation feature which I
haven't gotten to work yet but has
gotten some pretty interesting demos
I'll link Linus's video below it's a
beta it's a work in progress at best but
at the end of the day pixel buds they're
decent but they're just not quite airpot
the fact that it's not truly wireless
isn't a big deal for me but that is a
difference but just the whole taking
them out and putting them back in the
case is a bit more of a chore thanks to
that wire as great as this case is you
know it's pretty it's soft it's the only
one I've tried with USBC but I wish it
was a little more robust and a little
more elegant to use then just to look at
and the pixel buzzes themselves are a
little less comfortable in my ears just
because of the main inside of your ear
part being hard plastic usually with ear
buds you know you get that flexible
plastic or foam ear pods are sort of a
hit-or-miss and so our pixel buds
they're not flexible they don't try to
be super in here but they just kind of
hang on there I might sound like I'm
being picky but I really am I'm just
trying to find something that does
everything for Android as well as air
pods do for iPhone so we tested a bunch
of the other top options here that
worked for Android we tested the Bose
sound sport freeze we got the new j-bird
run we also did the j-bird x3 we got the
braggy - headphones the Jabra elite
sport the Arado Apollo 7 the Evo 1 and
the air pods which actually also do work
on Android technically turns out the
best comparison to what I got from air
pods on iPhone was what I got from
j-bird run on Android so I've talked
about jaybird stuff in the past and this
is obviously their newest completely
wireless earbuds set and it comes really
close in a lot of areas and does some
things better than air pods so as far as
the big three the case the instant
pairing and the ease of use the case
itself is a little bigger it's more
thick like bulbous still pocketable if
you want but you could also just toss it
in a bag not a huge deal and the
headphones come in and out of it pretty
quickly just gotta line up the pins and
drop it on the magnets and it starts
charging
not quite the same level as air pods but
you get the idea pairing is your normal
Android pairing the first time and then
every time you take them out the
case after that you just open it up and
it connects so again almost as good and
then ease-of-use is great you just
listen to it like normal or you can hop
in the j-bird and my sound app and mess
with audio profiles and changes the way
they sound that's something they've done
recently the seal in your ear with the
flexible custom tip is great so they
sound better than air pods for sure and
they fit in your ear better than air
pods or pixel buds especially for
workouts if you move around a lot these
are gonna sound great it is still
microUSB on the back I wish it was USB
see I've said that about other things
but pretty much everything else about
these as far as user experience goes
this is the air pods for Android as far
as what I've tried but of course for
those curious about all the other stuff
we tried here's a quick breakdown of the
rest so Bose sound support free 250
bucks they are a complete package with
good battery life sweat resistance
microphones nice build but they're big
the case is big the earbuds are big and
they have this this whole left-right
pairing priority so the right bud is the
master and the left one follows in a way
that gives a solid delay between your
audio and the stuff on your screen so
not so great for watching movies the
Arado Apollo 7 250 bucks again these are
a weird design and they sometimes fall
out your ears even with different sized
tips they're just kind of strange and
when they do stay in they look the most
like ear plugs not a whole lot of crazy
or extra features here just straight-up
ear plugs in a case no MIDI controls not
that great the braggy - 160 bucks
another big case and the earbuds
themselves are a lot more exposed to
pins lots of combinations of taps and
holds on the side touch pads for media
controls and just about everything you
could possibly want to do with these so
there's a learning curve to them but
there's also four gigs of internal
storage so that's cool the evo 1 or
yellow one 250 bucks a sleek case even
if it is micro USB the buds are not
sweat resistant so that's to note and
it's really easy to accidentally press
the media controls on the side when
you're trying to push them in your ears
because it's just a touch pad so that
was a bit frustrating they also sound
like hot garbage like truly impressive
are you sure it's not broken terrible
audio Jabra elite sport 220 bucks best
battery life of a bunch I'd say and you
can see why they're pretty chunky
stealthy all matte black sweat resistant
they connect pretty easy and the raise
indicators on the buds are nice but
there's two on each bud so you kind of
feel like you're shoving them in your
ears when you try to adjust them tons of
options for fit with the wingtips though
plus it has a heart rate monitor and
then j-bert x3 115 bucks these again are
also not wireless obviously but just to
note they still are really convenient
they sound great customizable fit with
the wingtips and ear buds again they
stay in your ears super well and there's
a clip to keep the flat wire behind your
head with a minimal slack so it doesn't
get caught in long hair also there's the
only one with media controls on the
cable not on the butt and then air pods
160 bucks so yes you can use air pods
for Android you might not want to but
it's decent
they pair like normal Bluetooth earbuds
and their sound is middle-of-the-road
obviously and you lose a couple of the
extra features like tapping for Siri and
the play pause when you go in and out of
your ears but otherwise pretty standard
so all that being said here's how I
would rank these as far as experience
for Android from best to worst number
one is j-bird run number two is j-bird
x3 number three pixel buds then braggy -
then I throw air pods in there then
Jabra elite sport bose sound sport urato
Apollo 7 hoping your favorite song plays
on the radio Yivo one so alright what
have we learned from all of this number
one that air pods are actually really
good I'm almost curious what a 2nd gen
ear pods would look like maybe a shorter
stem but that could be pretty
interesting number 2 that pixel buds are
pretty good wireless earbuds for Android
but not quite as good as air pods are
for iPhone although that almost doesn't
matter to anyone because most people
don't have both iPhones and Android
phones and number three that jaybird run
turns out to be pretty much the best
possible experience for wireless earbuds
for Android hopefully that covers
everything I think the ranking tells all
so that's pretty much it thank you for
watching and let me know what you think
of this general format I'm playing
around the idea of having trying to get
together everything from one category to
surface what really is the best maybe
there will be a name for it but let me
know if you think and also I'll try to
link everything I talked about in the
description below again thanks for
watching talk to you the next one peace